six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go next to our caller from the
three four seven area code who's calling
today from three four seven hello yeah
that's you oh one second let me get off
speaker please hi this is Kai from
Philadelphia hey guys
very good so yeah so I've been thinking
about like the rise of
anti-intellectualism end like
anti-vaxxers and the Americans that
don't believe that climate change was a
real issue yeah I was wondering how you
actually get through to those people
because it's it's really like the
biggest issue of is gonna we're going to
be safe together next decades yeah it's
an open question I mean I think what we
don't do is just like throw facts at
people even though we imagine hey if I
just got facts that didn't coincide with
what I think I would just change my
opinion maybe some of us would but for
most people that doesn't really work
what we've heard in our interviews with
people who have done documentaries and
and studied some of these anti science
movements works best is sort of empathic
listening to their perspective and and
sort of a respectful probing about what
would change their mind how did they
come to the conclusions and sort of
encouraging them to find contradictory
evidence on their own rather than sort
of like pummeling them over the head
with it but it's really difficult and
from you know I've said before like for
winning elections trying to change
people's minds isn't the good strategy
you're not going to be able to change
Trumpets minds nearly as easily as you
can just find progressives who don't
like Trump and convincing them to just
go and vote but you're right that when
it comes to society the anti-vaxxer real
impact right like we need to figure out
a strategy because we've got more
measles cases than we've had in 30 years
or whatever and I don't know what the
answer is right and I feel like I mean
climate change was gonna be our biggest
challenge in the next 20 years yeah I
was thinking and I know this would be a
weird strategy to like convince lack of
white nationalists
kind of people with that climate change
is an issue is that there's going to be
a huge migration crisis once like a lot
of a big issue is hit I'm not sure about
that so I've been trying so I've been
there's an open debate about whether
trying to appeal to your political
opposition on their values rather than
yours is effective but there are two
things that that are potentially
interesting when trying to talk to the
right about climate change one is if
you're a pro-business right winger it's
really hard for businesses to do well if
they're underwater it's really hard for
businesses to do well if you have people
who are having to migrate inland because
coastal cities are underwater and you're
making sort of the exact same point with
your idea and I don't know if that would
be effective I mean if you're coming if
you're truly a climate change denier in
that you simply don't think any of this
stuff is going to happen you probably
just ignore it and say sure the
migration crisis would be bad but it's
not going to happen because climate
change is fake yep absolutely kai thank
you Kai for a million great to hear from
you appreciate the phone call